Yeah.
So as usual, we'll just wait for
a couple of more minutes and
then we'll get started.
So what did you guys do the last
week?
You didn't have a glass, right?
Nice.
OK.
And still hoping for that one
student who says, you know, I
use those two hours to, you
know, study DSD.
Other PPT for today's session
available in canvas.
Yet no.
So as I told Rajesh, so it will
always be available after the
class.
Yeah, immediately after the
class, maybe like within 5 to 10
minutes after the class end,
there will be available.
Let me also quickly share the
screen.
Hi, good morning.
No, no.
The solutions for the homework
will not be uploaded.
It's just for you to, you know,
practice and you can verify
amongst yourself and so on.
Yeah, they're all very trivial
small problems.
So they will not be any official
key that I'll be uploading.
How about today?
Do you have a full day class
today?
Hi, good morning.
These sessions. OK.
OK, OK.
We'll wait for another two
minutes and then we'll get
started.
Yeah.
Today and tomorrow, we'll be on
track and then we'll follow the
usual schedule of Saturdays,
yeah.
Did you also get a chance to
look at the practice sheets?
Let me just bring the browser
here.
Yeah.
Let me know once the screen is
visible.
Yes.
No, maybe.
Are uh course canvas page right?
So inside this canvas page, the
moment we going to our course,
you'll also see a new section
called practice sheets, right?
So these sheets are actually
Python notebooks.
So currently there's only one,
but after two days class I'll be
uploading another couple of them
and so on.
Right after every class, I'll be
uploading some sheets.
We are all just self practice.
Once you can consider this to be
more like a lab session, maybe
right, you can just download
them and it'll open it and you
know Python notebooks and you
can just run each cell you know,
play around with it.
One right, that's the whole
idea.
There is nothing to do with the
exams or there's no lab exam or
these are not related to those.
It's just for you to just
practice and self try, yeah.
That sound good all of you.
If we don't confuse these with
your assignments and so on,
these are just.
Practice notebooks.
Yeah, just like your lab
programs.
Yeah.
Cool.
I think it's, uh, it's 35, so
it's good time for us to get
started.
So Shamshad had a question like,
yeah, we will come back to that.
Yeah.
So there are some exercises also
on that.
Maybe it's a good idea to try
that, and if you're not able to,
I'll upload some, you know
materials on that, but it's a
very ad hoc method.
It is not widely used because
you know, for complex problems
you'll not be able to draw such
trees, yeah.
Can you walk through the Python
practice you shared yesterday
towards.
Uh. Yeah.
OK.
Yeah, it's it's a very small
sheet.
It it the idea is that you'll
have to just execute each cell
and see for yourself.
You know what happens?
Cool.
That being said, let's get
started.
So welcome to the third contact
session for data structures and
algorithm design.
And today we will start our new
module, which is data
structures, right?
So what have we done so far?
So if you were there in the last
classes real quick, what did we
do in the last class?
Yeah, nobody.
It's been a while, but what
exactly did we do in the last
two classes?
Types of recursive methods.
Yeah, very good master's
theorem.
Yeah, time complexity, right?
What else?
So we started the course with
this motive of why should we
even learn data structures and
algorithms right?
And after convincing ourselves
that even in data science, and
then we need data structures and
algorithms, and you know,
problem solving, we started with
what is an algorithm?
The property is the analysis of
it, the time complexity, and you
know the RAM model and all of
those.
And then we also learned about
how do you analyze algorithms,
right?
So if it is an iterative
algorithm, you will write it.
You'll write the pseudo code
right and then you will use your
counting primitives method and
you will summarize it and after
summarizing it you will simplify
it and then we learned about 2
rules.
Do you remember about that?
Yeah, 2 rolls neglecting the
lower order term and also
cancelling the constant right.
Once you do that, you will get
some answer and that you will
put it in the asymptotic
notation and in our case we
agreed that always we'll go for
worst case analysis, right?
Which is the big one notation
and then the last class.
We broke some myths about, you
know, just because there is 2
loops, it doesn't mean the
complexity is, you know, and
square and so on.
And we'll have two
systematically inspect the code,
and then we went about learning
about recursion and about how do
you, you know, form a recurrence
relation?
How do you solve that using
Masters theorem and all the
cases and so on right?
So it was just more of a request
goes to the course.
So the first two classes, that
is what we did, but today we
will get started with data
structures.
We will get started in specific
about linear data structures.
We will learn what is a array.
What is the stack?
What is a queue?
What is a linked list?
And so on.
And then we will wind it up for
today and tomorrow.
Again, we will start with
another data structure like
trees and then graphs and so on.
This is what we will keep doing
till our mid semester exam.
Right, this is what we did in
the last class.
Cool.
So what are the different
operations that we can do on
data?
Yeah, you can typically add more
data to a collection right?
For example, if there is this
whole class, if there's a
student that joins today, I can
add this data to this collection
auto someone is already done
with me.
Don't want to attend this course
anymore.
I can remove the data from the
data collection which is delete
or remove or he can ask
questions about the data in the
data collection.
I can ask if such and so you
know person exists or not, or
you know I can update some
values to it and so on right?
In other words, web programmers
and other people call this
correct operations, right?
You can create.
You can read, you can update
something or you can delete.
Is there anything else that you
can do on data?
Yeah, ultimately it all boils
down to this, right?
Do do, do, do data science.
You know, whole analytics
pattern and all that.
But at the end it falls into
some of these buckets, right?
Either you're curious about the
data, you you do something on
it, or you are actually deleting
it or inserting it.
Yeah, Amit.
Yeah, update is already here,
right?
So either you insert or delete
or you ask questions about it
right, you either update it or
you search about it you you see
if there are some patterns
existing and so on.
This is all we can do right?
So now based on these
operations, there are several
data structures, right?
So there are a lot more than
what we will learn in this
course right from array stacks,
queues, linked list, doubly
linked list, trees, heaps,
graphs.
You know, 2-3 trees, 24 trees,
KD trees and you know, red black
trees and whatnot, right?
But ultimately our guiding, you
know principle on which data
structure should I choose,
right?
So that would depend on these
operations.
I'm going to keep inserting a
lot of data in my use case, or
am I just going to search data
or am I just going to keep
deleting data right?
Such type of choice is what will
guide us.
So firstly, what is a linear
data structure?
So broadly speaking, data
structures are classified into
two types, linear and nonlinear.
So in a linear data structure,
data is organized in a linear
fashion.
Yeah, examples are are a stack
Q, vector, list, sequence, and
so on.
And by this linear fashion, do
we mean in memory?
Also they are linear.
What is your thoughts on it?
Linear meaning one after the
other, right?
So whatever data structures fall
under linear data structures,
they are going to be in a
sequence one after the other,
right?
But that necessarily doesn't
mean they should be next to next
in memory.
Yeah, let us nonlinear data
structures.
They are organized in a
nonlinear fashion, right.
There is some relationship that
exists among the data.
You cannot put all of them next
to next right, like trees,
graphs and so on.
When the time comes, we will
explore them in detail.
Don't worry about it.
Arise.
Arise is the first example of
linear data structure, and he's
a special guy because not just
conceptually he's linear, but
even in the memory the elements
are sitting next to next right
in the true sense they are
linear in nature.
So what is this array?
So Array is a finite set of
homogeneous elements stored in
adjacent or contiguous memory
locations.
It is represented by a single
name, so break it down right.
So what does it say?
Finite, so it is always defined
by a capital N, right?
You'll have to tell how many
elements do I want.
Is it file elements or is it 50
elements or is it 500 elements?
I need to set that five.
Yeah, it cannot grow
dynamically.
We'll have to set that finite
number.
It is the homogeneous elements.
So what does this really mean?
What does homogeneous elements?
Can I have some number some
elements as number?
Some where's names?
Somewheres, you know not
possible, right?
So all of them should be of the
same data type.
That is what homogeneous means,
and then they are also stored in
the contiguous memory locations.
All of them are next to next in
memory as well, and all of them
share the same name.
So in this case this whole array
is named as a, so this is
pointed by a zero.
This is pointed by a one.
This is a two and so on, meaning
array indices start from zero,
right and go all the way till
and minus one.
So if it is 5 array indexes will
be 01234 right?
If there are any element in that
area, the last element will be
of n -, 1.
The first element can be
accessed by a zero.
Second, can be accessed by a one
and so on.
So now I have a couple of
questions for you.
I want to access the third
element here, this third
element, right?
How will you reference that?
What will I call him?
Because all of them have the
same name, A of two very good.
If I hit directly of two, I'll
go reach this position.
I'll be able to take that
element.
What is the complexity then?
If we want to go ahead and get
this value, the complexity is
constant, right?
Very good.
Yeah, because all I'm doing is
I'm doing a of two.
I directly go to that memory
location.
I get that value respective of
whichever position I want.
I can directly go there.
I can get that value right?
So getting a value from an array
is not a problem, right?
But it has its own
disadvantages.
We will come to that.
Yeah.
When the time comes, we will
look at it.
Yeah.
This clear guys for all of you
arrays.
Yes.
No, maybe simple stuff.
Just a point for you to ponder
about the problem with this guy,
right?
Let's say suppose I had created
an array with five elements or
five slots, have now put all the
five elements here.
I want another element to be put
here, but there is no space.
So what can I do now?
The only option available for me
is to recreate a new array.
There are also chances that in
the memory there is no place
here, right?
So next to this there can be
some other you know file or
whatever right?
There is no space here.
Maybe so.
In those cases and replace also
not an option, right?
Krishna, I want all these five
elements plus I want the six
7th, 8th element.
I don't want to replace anything
right then my only option is
I'll have to recreate a new
array somewhere else in memory
which are bigger space, right?
Maybe say 10 elements or say 100
elements and then I should copy
all these elements again for
that and then insert my new 6th
element right?
So such problem is there with
arrays.
That is usually say it cannot
dynamically grow or shrink.
I love to write away, define the
number of elements or the
capital N and once that is
defined dynamically, it cannot
just grow or it cannot even
shrink.
Shrink.
Meaning, what if I have only
three elements here?
Then these two are going empty,
meaning I'm wasting space here.
So these are the pros and cons
of Aries.
So now let's look into, you
know, something called stacks.
A stack is a container of.
This is again a data structure.
There's also a linear data
structure.
A stack is a container of
objects that are inserted and
removed according to the last in
first out principle or it is
also called as Lee.
Four objects can be inserted at
any time, but only the last
object can be removed.
Getting it right so it follows a
principle.
This is a paradigm.
Yeah, you have to obey this
paradigm whenever you work in
the stack ecosystem.
In this world, you can insert
anytime whatever you want, but
only the last one that you
inserted will be the one to get
removed.
You cannot just remove whatever
you like, right?
It follows this order of lasting
first out the last one who went
into the structure will be the
first one to get out, and there
are some terminologies.
So inserting or adding an item
in this stack is called as
pushing onto the stack or it is
also called as push and removing
or deleting from a stack is
called as popping or pop and
pushing and popping happens only
in one end and that is called as
top right?
So let's see some examples.
They're all day to day examples
that you might have seen, so
you'll see a stack of plates, a
stack of coins, a stack of box,
a stack of folded shirts, and so
on.
Right.
So in all of this, for example,
I now you know want to put
another shirt in this.
Where can I put it able to the
bottom or middle or somewhere?
Or where is the only place I can
put the shirt?
Yeah.
Any idea on top always here?
This is where I can put and.
Now someone wants to take a
shirt from here.
Which one is the one that we can
take?
Again, the top one right, only
this shirt can be taken out.
I cannot randomly pull this
white shirt or something, right?
Similarly, a lot of examples,
right?
So if you love cooking, you
might have done this right?
So after every roti you keep
placing them like a stack here,
right?
You keep placing them on this
one, so the stack is growing
like this.
The height of the, you know, the
pile of proteins are growing and
when someone is hungry, when
they want to take the roti out,
they'll take this first roti out
of it, right?
They will not pull it from the
middle or from the bottom.
They'll take it from the top, so
insertion and deletion both are
happening when only one end,
which is called the top end
right and the last one who went
right.
So this was the roti which was
last placed here after cooking
and that is the one first to be,
you know, taken out similarly.
Have you even seen this?
Yeah.
Ellie maker, right.
So here as well, this is the
last plate which was put inside
and after cooking this will be
the first one to get out
familiar coin dispenser right?
The last one which was, you know
put inside will be the first
one.
It'll give it out to us.
Yeah.
Is the motivation clear for all
of you?
Yes.
No, a very simple philosophy
insertion or removal, which in
this world is called push and
pop.
Both will happen in only one
end, and that end is called as
top right, whichever was the one
who went last will be the first
one to get out.
Cool.
That being said, let's implement
this stack.
How do you implement it?
We can implement it in two ways.
Either I can use an array or I
can use a linked list, but we
have not even learned what is a
link list now, so we will learn
later about linked list and then
we will see how we can implement
a stack using linked list.
But for now, let's learn how to
implement a stack using an
array.
Create a stack, yes, using an
array by specifying the maximum
size N great.
Something like this.
So is it now a array or a stack
you have just created a array.
We have named it as yes and it
is going all the way from zero
to n -, 1.
Basically, we've just created an
array.
The stack consists of North
Element array yes and an integer
variable T right, which is
nothing but the top element.
Aren't they start from zero, so
we initialized T 2 -, 1.
So initially the top is minus
one.
Whenever we add an element, we
keep incrementing that right.
It's been incremented top.
We put an element we incremented
element, we put an element and
so on.
So we've kept on doing this.
This Violet color means we have
put all these elements now and
now it is here right?
So now I want to insert another
element.
So what should I be doing?
Any idea?
Of course I have some space
here.
I'll be able to do that.
So whenever I want to push an
item, what is the operation that
I'm doing?
Yeah.
Why t + 2?
I'm just going one place, right?
So what is T is the top element.
It is always given by the
topmost element, the address of
the top element, right?
So in this case, all these
Violet colored are filled, so
he's pointing to the topmost
element.
Who's there?
Right.
He's the potential guy, that
element, which is pointed by
this T will be the one who will
get popped out when you do a pop
operation, right?
So you'll always point to the
top most roti, right?
So now I want to insert a new
item or in other words I want to
do a push operation so the
operation is T is equal to T +
1.
All of you are right.
I'll be going to this position
and I will put my new element,
say 100 that would malament
here.
I want to again do a push
operation.
I'll go here.
I'll put my item and T will be
pointing to this top most
element which is 200 now, right?
Now I have a question.
Can you go ahead and randomly
remove these items?
Is it possible?
Yeah, not really.
Right.
So now in this case, what is the
only item that I can delete now
in this current state, which is
the only element that I can
remove 200 right?
Only 200 I can remove and then
what should I do
programmatically?
How will you do that?
I will make this to be null.
I will do T is equal to P -, 1,
right.
So now T will point here, then
heard hundred is the topmost
right.
If I want to delete him, I will
delete that hundred.
I'll again make T is equal to t
-, 1.
I can keep doing that, right?
Cool.
This is one example, but there
are also some other
terminologies here.
For example, if I insert another
item here, right, let's say I
didn't delete them.
I've inserted here as well and
now TC pointing here.
Now I want to insert another
item.
I'll do T equal to T + 1.
So what will happen here?
What will be the value of T?
Yeah.
It it it went to N right it it
is actually out of bounds and
that particular case in stacks
is called as Stack Overflow.
Yeah.
I'm very fond name.
Most of you would have, you
know, Googled about your errors
and there's a website called,
you know Stack Overflow and all
that.
Right.
So we have got inspired from
here that when the whole stack
is filled and still if you are
trying to insert something you
will not be able to do so.
You will go out of bounds and
that condition is called as
Stack Overflow.
An example could be that, let's
say suppose there is a bucket
filled with water.
You're still trying to pour
water, right?
You will not be able to.
The water will spill out.
That condition is called
overflow.
Similarly, in other thing can
happen, so I keep deleting them.
I delete every item here and I
have the last item.
I've deleted that also.
Now there are no elements here
and at that stage I am again
trying to go do a pop.
I'm trying to remove something
right stack is empty, but you're
still trying to remove something
that is called stack underflow,
right?
And analogy would be that you
know this.
No water in the bucket.
You're still trying to, you
know, take a mug of water from
it.
Not possible, right?
So that is stack underflow.
A couple of you know simple
algorithms for you.
Sites right?
So what exactly?
Then how is it different from
array?
Because this too has the limit.
Yeah, it has the limit, but it
follows that paradigm, right?
You cannot randomly take an
element.
You cannot randomly insert
something or remove something,
right?
It is always this top element
will give the topmost element
and only in that direction you
can do either push or pop.
That is why this is a stack.
Yeah.
Is that clear, Krishna?
We are using array to implement
this paradigm of stack right
which is last come you know last
in first out our indices started
0 so we initialize 2 -, 1 yes.
So because initially otherwise
our whole, you know logic will
get different, right?
So initially we will have it as
minus one, so it'll go to zero.
I'll put my item there.
I'll go to one, put my item
there and so on, right?
But can we access any element
from inventory?
No, we cannot do that.
Yeah, we have to always rely on
only the top.
Yeah, we cannot even, you know,
directly access in between.
And so on.
All that we have is the T.
That's all.
We don't have any other, you
know, pointers, indexes and so
on, right? Cool.
How do you initialize the stack
in a code and how to
differentiate it?
Yeah.
We will come to all that.
Yeah, I will be uploading a
notebook.
Also, don't worry about that.
Yeah, we will initialize it like
a normal array with capital
north, right?
We will give it a S10 size or 50
size and initially all of them
will be just, you know, junk
values.
So now let's you know, look at
some small pseudo codes which is
really important, yeah.
First of all, what is the size?
Yeah.
So there's a very subtle
difference, guys.
We have been talking about
capital N, right?
So what is capital N?
Capital N is not the size.
Yeah.
We'll look at these codes and
then it'll be all clear.
Yeah.
So we.
Yeah, we were doing T equal to t
-.
One yeah, we did.
Not directly initialize it to be
equal to minus one.
We'll look at all this example.
It'll be even more clear.
Yeah.
So this capital N is the total
capacity, right?
So whenever we are creating that
stack using an array, we are
defining the total capacity
right?
That is my capital N there is
no.
By size I mean how many elements
are there currently right in
order to get that I will use
deep plus one.
So in this example, how many
elements are there?
You'll tell me the capacity is
how much?
What is capital N?
Capital N is 6 and how many
elements are currently occupied.
There are four elements
currently.
How do we get that four?
Where is T.
Currently, we will always point
to me top most element right?
Where is it pointing currently?
He will point to the topmost
element, so T is pointing to
this position three since RENI
start from zero, I should do a +
1 right?
So this T + 1 will always give
me how many elements are there
inside this stack currently.
Is this core clear for all of
you the size algorithm?
Size means the number of
elements in the stack.
It is not the whole capacity
then anyway I can just return
capital N right?
That was wrong.
Size means how many elements are
currently there and how to get
that.
I will get it using top whereas
top will be a little misleading
because arrays start from zero,
so I should do A T + 1 and that
will always give me how many
elements are there in this
stack.
Cool.
What about the next algorithm?
Algorithm is empty.
This seudo code is going to give
me a true if that stack is
empty, otherwise he's going to
give me a false.
So in this case, how do you know
that?
So whenever a stack is empty,
what will be the T value?
So do we they initial state or
when you have inserted and you
have removed everything, what
will be the T value minus one
right?
So I can use that in my
condition.
I can say if value is minus one
then return it true true meaning
is empty is true.
Yes, it is empty.
Otherwise, return it as false.
So in this particular example,
what is my T value?
I go to this line.
I see that my T value is.
Three right is not equal to
minus one, so I'll go ahead and
return it as false.
Yeah, that was also correct.
In this case, my stack is having
elements.
It is not empty, so I'll give it
as false.
He's the second code.
Also clear for all of you is
empty.
Is always going to return true
if the whole stack is empty.
What about this example in this
example, if I run my is empty,
will give true or false.
My K value is currently minus
one.
Nobody is there inside this.
So you will give it true and if
I run the size algorithm on it,
what will the size algorithm
give me as answer?
Size algorithm says T + 1 T is
minus one, so minus 1 + 1 is 0.
So it will give me a zero and
which is correct.
I have zero elements inside this
perfect.
What about top right top mining?
I'm asking who is the topmost
element right?
I'm not asking the index of it,
I'm asking who is present in
that location, who's the top
most element, the one who got
inserted last, right.
Who's that?
I'm going to ask him how do I
get that right?
Please repeat just the last one.
Which one should be?
You mean the EMT one or the last
example was is MD so in this
case it is minus one, so it will
return it as true.
It'll return it as true and in
this same example I asked in
this case if I invoke the size
algorithm, what will happen?
So size algorithm told T + 1.
What is the value in my case it
is minus one here, so I'll do
minus one and this plus one is
there minus 1 + 1 is 0 so it
will return that zero is its
size and is that correct here?
Yes, it is the size.
There is no element at all
inside all of the slots are
free, right?
So that is what it is.
Yeah.
Can you explain T equal to minus
one so that is initialization?
Yeah.
So at the very beginning, when
the stack is empty, we as in T
value as minus one.
Yeah, that condition itself can
also be used to recognize that
the stack is empty.
How to get the capacity of the
stack that you always have it in
capital N right?
Because you are only creating
the stack using this capital N
so at any time in the program,
if you just print your capital
N, you are going to get the
capacity and that is in your
control.
You are only going to choose the
capacity of it, right?
Cool.
What about the next algorithm
which is top?
These empty so again here also
there is a you know trick here
right that is you want to know
the topmost element but what if
there is no element?
There's a problem, right?
I want you to give me the
topmost element, but in the
current stage, if there are no
elements then there is a
problem, right?
So here we are, first checking
if it's empty is true, then just
throw an error telling that no,
I cannot give you the top
element because the whole stack
is empty.
Otherwise I will go to a soft
stack of tea.
I'll pick up the topmost element
right?
So in this example, who is T?
He is pointing to three, so as
soft is nothing but a soft three
and S of three is nothing but
41.
That is my top most element.
Yeah.
Yes.
No.
Maybe all of you.
We'll come there, guys.
Yeah. Don't jump the bridge,
ANIKET.
All of you?
Yeah, we'll come there.
So far are these three
algorithms clear?
Yeah, size of it is T + 1 is
empty.
You can always check using your
T if it is minus one topmost
element, you'll always get it by
soft, but there is a trick
there.
That is, if there are no
elements, how will you give the
top most right?
So I'll put an error there error
check if that is not the case.
If there are any elements, then
I'll pick up that topmost
element. Well.
Now let's go to the push
algorithm.
Push and pop are the heart of
the stack.
You clearly observed here in the
push word in the bracket you
also see something here, right?
What is that?
Yeah, real quick.
Item to be inserted right?
So there is an argument there,
so that is the argument or
element that I want to push
that.
Oh, right, it can be anything.
You can your name or whatever it
is that argument which I want to
insert here.
Also, I should do a check
correct?
We already spoke about it.
You've already the bucket is
full.
How can you fill right?
So I will check if this size is
equal to N size algorithm you
already learned.
That is, if my size becomes
capacity correct then I will not
be able to insert right?
So I will throw an error telling
Stack overflow other ways as you
are already replied, I will do T
equal to T + 1 in that location.
I will put my object, so let's
do that.
Let's do that in this example.
Yeah, all of you just focus for
a minute.
Then we will take up all these
questions.
Yeah.
So in this case, what is size?
Yeah.
No, this is this is just a
placeholder, MANISHA.
Yeah, this O is a name of it.
Inside that there is a number.
Yeah.
So you can have MANISHA here
that MANISHA is the variable
name and inside that I'm having
the value.
OK, cool.
So in this case my K value is 4,
his four equal to make capacity
6 no.
So I'll be able to insert so I
do T equal to T + 1.
I come to this position and I
put my object there.
I want to insert 50 now I insert
50 here.
Well, I want to insert one more.
What do we do now?
My what is my size now in this
case?
I have already inserted, you
know, a couple of elements.
My size is 5 so this line what
will we do?
We will check if five is equal
to six. No.
So I will do T equal to T + 1.
That is from four to five in
that position.
Let S of five position.
I'll go and put my new element,
let's say this O in my example
now is 100.
I'll put that 100 here.
I think so.
Now also I want to again insert
right now again I go to this
line what is my size?
Yeah, yeah, I mean I that's
right.
Yeah, you can also use this,
correct?
Yeah.
Now in this case my size value
has already become six, so six
is equal to six.
Is true, right?
This line is now true.
So now I cannot insert anything
else right?
I'm already Phil, so I will
throw this error telling the
stack is overflowing.
I cannot insert this new
element.
Cool, and Vinay had a very
important doubt, he told.
You spoke about all that pseudo
code and all that, but why are
you violating?
Right.
So this SOFT line should have
been actually like this,
correct?
As Aiment in pseudocode is
technically like this symbol,
this is how you have to do,
right?
But we have used the equal to
here.
So he's like, you know, but it
is still agreed upon, right, as
long as you're able to
understand it is, you know,
still fine.
Yeah, but technically this is
what is correct.
I would urge you to do it like
this way, yeah.
All the push algorithm is it
clear for all of you.
Yes.
No, maybe.
Correct in here also I have used
this notation only right equally
equal to I have not used the
single equal to cool.
I mean both these examples I
have used a notation like a
programming language itself.
Cool.
What about pop algorithm?
Yeah, very cool algorithm.
Again for Pop, I have not given
which element to you know
delete.
Why is that?
Yeah.
Very good.
Yeah, always the last meaning
the last element.
Who was inserted?
Yeah.
So it is very evident I should
not tell you what to delete in a
stack.
It's already known that whoever
is in the top element, who he'll
be the one who will get deleted,
so I need not mention anything
which again there is a problem.
What if that whole stack itself
is empty?
How can I check that it's empty
right?
This method that we learned I'll
put if it's empty.
It's true.
Then throw an error that stack
is underflow.
I cannot remove anything because
stack is already empty.
What do you want me to remove?
Right.
I'll throw that error.
Otherwise, what I want to do is
I want to remove that element
who's in the top and where is
that element as of T right.
In this case this is my SP which
is 41.
So I'm actually just taking and
keeping it in another variable.
Is equal to South of three that
is equal to 41 and then that
position S of T and making it
null.
Meaning here instead of 41 I'm
making it null and then I'm
doing equal to t -, 1.
So my top value from 3 is now
slowly going to two and finally
I'm returning that evalue 41
telling he is the guy who got
deleted.
But actually speaking all this
is just a good programming
practice.
Just this line is also good
enough as long as you, you know,
decrement your top value here
that 41 will be there, but when
you push some other item it will
get overwritten right?
But don't do all that.
It is all a bad programming
practice.
We just want to, you know, keep
it in a variable and then we can
just print telling that, you
know, he's the 41 who got
deleted.
Thing like that, technically,
but you don't need all that
statements if you want to have a
very small code.
You don't need this line.
You don't need the last line.
Yeah, only these two are also
good enough.
And as I told, this null line is
also not needed the next time
when you post something it will
get overwritten, but it's a good
practice that whenever you
delete something, put it as a
null, right?
He's a clear guys for all of
you.
Yeah.
Where do we making it null
because we are deleting it
right?
It's a good practice that when
you remove something you make
that value as null, right?
But even if you don't do so,
it's fine.
As I told when you again insert
something that 41 would have got
overwritten.
So I need to get the current
value of T we should have read
the whole of stack initially for
all these algorithms, right?
Correct.
Yeah, you can't directly go take
something.
T will be your writer.
Whatever you want to do, you
have to do only using T either T
equal to T + 1 including the
push and T equal to t -, 1
during the pop, right yes, no.
If you understood stack and
their operations, so today I'll
be uploading a Python notebook
which has Python code for all
this, right?
So then you will just, you know,
run them and see, you know what
happens and so on.
Yeah, Null gets assigned.
Yeah, there's nothing much that
is your cost course right in
your memory.
Also, you'll be able to, you
know, so it's more like a wipe
off of that, you know, memory
cell.
It's no all of you, yeah.
What have we insert our element?
Uh, but we forget to delete a T
value.
Yeah.
Then you are messing it up.
Yeah.
So technically, if you see here,
firstly you should increment
then only you can insert right.
You cannot just insert first,
first clear off to agreement,
then you will go to the empty
space, then add the element
here, right?
So.
So those are in order you.
You cannot forget it.
And so on.
Yeah, if you forget it, it's
simply means you are making a
mistake there.
Yeah, but it is just
implementation in array.
We can take data from anywhere,
correct?
But in a stack you should not.
Yeah.
So no, forget that you know you
are using an array it it is a
stack.
You believe that it is a stack,
right?
You should not directly go ahead
and you know, use this as of two
and you know, take that element
and all that.
Correct, because the underlying
is the array, but now you are
convinced that you are
implementing a stack, so you
should not just go and you know
take some values from there in
the 5th algorithm, just as laid
out.
Can we use another algorithm
within an algorithm?
What do you mean by that, Vinay?
This one, you mean?
Yeah, of course.
Yeah, here also I'm using size
right here.
Also, I'm using the same T here.
Also, I'm using SMT which is
another algorithm.
Yeah, of course I want to do
that.
Otherwise I have to write that
code again here that whole piece
of code I should write here.
Instead of that, I'm calling
that function.
Yeah, you cannot update and so
on.
You have to either add or insert
if you want to update, you have
to go till there and you know
you have to add the new element
there.
That's it, yeah.
You know you cannot answer on
and.
Yeah, yeah, that is what I'm
again and again reiterating,
forget that it is an array, it
is not an array.
You are using an array to
implement stack, meaning you can
only do these operations Bush,
pop.
You can get the top most you can
know if it is, you know empty or
not.
You can know you know what is
the size of it.
Or of course, you can also know
if it is full or not by checking
a in all ties with the capital.
You cannot go in between or.
You cannot take these elements
and you know all that.
We cannot do right?
It's no.
Is it clear for all of you?
We'll take some examples.
Yeah.
How to check where is my current
value that is a variable right
in your program you will be able
to get it whenever you print it,
you will get the T value.
These just, you know variable
right?
Consider an array based
implementation of stack.
Yes, assume that the maximum
size of the stack is is 3.
So what is this three now?
The one who gets this right gets
a goodie.
What is this 3 value denoting?
Yeah, very good.
This is a capital N it is not
the size.
Yeah, this is capital N someone
got it wrong, JAGDISH.
No, it is capital yen. Yeah.
So the contents of this track at
each step for the following
sequence of operations mentioned
the exceptions like empty or
full, if any.
So there are some operations
given to us.
So firstly I have my stack like
this.
It has three slots because my
capital N is 3.
Firstly, I'll have to do a push,
so currently the indexes are
growing like this.
So where is my T value now?
So it'll be in others.
Where is my K value.
Yeah, T value is always assigned
to minus one in the beginning,
right?
Devalues minus one here.
If they want to insert, what
should I do?
I should do T equal to T + 1 and
then insert it in that location.
So if I do A T + 1 in the this
place, what will happen from
minus one?
I'll go to the zero to sell
right from minus one.
If I do plus one, it will become
zero, so I'll go to this cell in
that I want to push this one.
I've pushed it and now what is
my top value?
Top value 0 right?
This is 0.
This is 1 this is 2.
Again, I want to do a pop if I
do a pop, what would happen?
I will again remove this one and
what will be the top value
again.
I inserted this one again.
I'm removing it.
If I remove it again, it will go
back to.
This one will get removed and
then my top value will become
minus one.
Perfect.
What about next?
I want to push too, so two will
come here.
Right.
I have pushed it top value 0 now
right.
I want to again push 3 have
pushed 3 right at this stage.
Where is the top value?
Very good.
Yeah, top is pointing here to
the top most element and the top
most element is home.
Yeah, top most element top most
element is 3, right?
This is the topmost element and
he's given by the index one
well.
Again, I have to do another
push.
I'm doing that also which you
stand and my top value is too.
What is the size of the stack
now?
Size, not capacity.
What is the size now?
Size is also three capacities
also three.
Now I'm planning to push five.
Will I be able to do that?
I cannot push 5 here because my
size is already equal to
capacity, right?
So I'll throw an error telling
that my stack is full or stack
overflow.
I will not be able to push it.
OK, what about pop?
After I remove this, what will
be the top value?
Yeah.
Anyone after I remove this pop
it will become.
Right.
I'm doing a pop forgot remote.
My top came here.
I'm removing this three, then
top will come to two.
I'm ruining this also.
I'll go to zero at that stage.
If I do another pop I will get
stack control flow.
I will not be able to do
anything because this pop is
telling.
Remove something, but already
there is nothing here, right?
Yeah.
Is this clear guys for all of
you?
Yes.
No.
Maybe the whole operation of,
you know, inserting removal,
stack overflow, stack underflow,
all of this.
Yes.
No.
OK, So what are the
disadvantages of this? Right.
The advantage is that if you are
using array based
implementation, the first pop
should remove four rate correct
first date removed four then it
removed three then it removed
two then it was empty and that
empty stage you tried to remove
the pop it which it could not.
It told that there is an error.
They are top is noted as the
correct.
You can have it as the whole
word top.
Also no problem.
Yeah, it removed it. Kevin.
Yeah, I'm not sure what's going
on.
There's a lot of, you know, lag
in the chat.
We removed four.
Then we removed three.
Then we removed two.
Then there was nothing.
No, no, no, I I just, you know,
showed the state and in this
time applying pop so forgot
remote in this time applying
again a pop.
So three got remote in this I
again applied a pop so two got
remote something like that.
Yeah, yeah, correct.
So it is very simple and
efficient because all that you
can do is just insert by using T
equal to T + 1 or remove using T
equal to t, -, 1 and it is very
simple to do and it is constant.
You know, time complexity, it
has disadvantage.
We already spoke.
There's an upper bound capital N
on the size of the stack.
The arbitrary value N maybe too
small for a given application,
or it might be a wastage of
memory right?
But now I have a question.
This disadvantage is it the
disadvantage of the stack
itself?
Or is it because of the array?
Yeah.
So in that will also be a stack
as long as you follow the
paradigm last in first out it is
a stack.
Yeah, all of you are right, this
problem is not actually because
of the stack.
It is because of the underlying
array, because array has a
problem, it cannot grow
dynamically or you know it
cannot shrink.
So it is a problem of the array
which is then becoming a problem
of stack also right because you
are using array to implement it.
Cool.
That is why we will use a better
approach using list.
No.
What are the applications of
this data structure?
Some of you might be like, you
know, all this top topmost is
all fine.
Like you know, pushing, popping.
But why should I even learn
about stack, right?
Because it is very, very, you
know, important for our systems
to work.
There are plenty of applications
of stack, right?
A couple of them have mentioned
here, stacks can be used for
expression evaluation.
Yeah, I'll.
I'll talk about that now and
stacks can be used to convert
from one form of expression to
another.
Yeah.
In this PPT there is an appendix
I have given that in detail you
can have a look at that.
I'll briefly also touch upon
that now stacks can be used to
check parenthesis matching in an
expression, right?
Are you getting it?
These type of parenthesis we use
in our programs right?
So I can I can actually use
stack in order to match this
whenever there is an opening,
I'll push it onto the stack
whenever there is a
corresponding bracket.
Whenever there is a closing
bracket, I'll pop something out
right and I will match if there
is the same one or not.
Yeah.
So I will leave it to you to
explore more about that.
Yeah, it's there in your book,
but this is the fundamental, you
know, picture for example here.
If I had this bracket, then when
I, you know encounter this, I'll
pop something from the stack
from the pop.
I'll get this bracket, but what
I have in hand is this.
There is a mismatch, right?
So that is a problem, but it can
be used for, you know,
parenthesis matching and stack
data structure.
Are you also used in
backtracking problems like
recursion?
Right.
Cool.
So let's you know, get into the
expressions and so on, and then
we will take it forward from
there.
If we want to delete the first
element when the size is yen,
then the case is correct.
That's right.
You know Divya, but we are
always talking about one delete
operation.
One delete operation is big O of
1.
If I want to do yen deletion
then that is of course we go of
yen, right?
But always we are giving that
complexity of 1 operation not
for the whole you know set.
Yeah, so far, so good.
All of you with me?
Yeah.
Can we get started with
expressions and how stacks are
being used here?
Yeah, real quick, just early
morning.
I don't see any responses.
Yeah, T is just the index,
ANIKET.
Yeah, not the top element
itself.
Yes, of T will give you the top
element.
These just the index.
Cool.
So let's see about these
expressions.
This is all your computer
organization course, but I just
want to you know, that's about
it.
Maybe some of you might not know
this, so there are three types
of expressions. Yeah.
So human beings, as human
beings, we use the infix
notation, right?
Even in your math classes in
your childhood, you always use
this notation where the operator
symbol.
What is an operator?
Can you give some examples?
Yeah.
Your place minus and all those,
so that becomes your operator,
right?
And what is your upper Rand?
Yeah, operand is nothing but a
BCD, or you know, you can have
1000.
You are numbers and you are
variables.
So if you're pure operator in
between operand, then that is
called as infix notation.
Yeah, that is how we we usually
use mathematical notations, and
even in our programs, this is
how we use it. Whereas there are
other two notations called
prefix and put.
Postfix prefix notation is also
called as Polish notation, and
in this case the operator is
placed before the operand.
Something like this, less a, B
-, C, D into eight and so on,
where the operator comes first,
then the operand can post fix
notation.
Is the exact opposite of it.
It is also called as reverse
Polish notation, where the
operator symbol is placed after
its operand.
Thing like this right A/B plus
ad into and so one where the
operator is coming after the
operand.
Yeah.
Is this clear guys for all of
you and your computers, don't
use infix notation at all.
Yeah.
And I would also urge you why?
Yeah, go look.
You know, into your book or no
in the Internet on why are
computers do not use in fix
notation.
This is a very solid reasoning
why it doesn't use it.
Our computer will always use
only the post fix notation or
prefix notation, and most modern
day hardware use postfix
notations, right?
Is this clear?
Guys, all of you?
Yes.
No, maybe in fix is the one that
we are using.
If you put the symbol first then
it is prefix.
If you put the symbol after the
operand, it is postfix and our
computer will always use only
postfix or prefix.
But as human beings, that is
difficult for us.
We always use infix, so now how
do I convert an infix notation
into a post fix notation?
You can use stack right?
That is what I have given as an
appendix in this deck.
If I have an expression like
this A+B into C and if I want to
convert this.
If I want to convert this into
other notation right?
Like post fix notation, I will
be able to make use of my stack
and I will be able to do that.
Right.
He asked Ruby.
Yeah, this is the example.
Prefix is this, let's say B -, C
These are all examples of
prefix.
In this clear guys, we all go
through the appendix.
That is a separate algorithm.
Yeah, that's a separate
algorithm on how to use a stack
in order to convert this.
Right there is another one,
which is how do you evaluate
this postfix expression, right?
There's a post fix expression
given to you.
How do you evaluate and get the
final answer for that?
Also we can use stack and that
is the example I'll show you
now.
Add a ) at the end of the
arithmetic expression.
Yes, this CF is in which
notation?
Can someone correctly guess
that?
Yeah.
Exactly.
Post fix whatever is given to us
is not in.
In fix that is in post fix.
Yeah, there is already an
algorithm.
It has converted infix to
postfix and that post fix
notation.
We are now evaluating to get
that final answer right.
So this F is in postfix
notation.
Scan that from left to right and
repeat steps three and four till
we reach that Sentinel bracket
that we had only put.
So this is just the end of
marker guys.
You can just put, you know
whatever you like.
Yeah, that that is to denote
that my algorithm is over
though.
Is the algorithm say if an
operand is encountered, put it
onto the stack or push it onto
the stack.
If an operator is encoded.
Yeah, very important.
This is not multiply.
This is just a placeholder.
This indicates any operator.
OK, it can be placed minus into,
you know, power.
Whatever you know, operator, if
you encounter that, then what
should you do?
Remove the two top elements from
the stack where yen one is the
top element and N2 is the next
to two top element.
Perform N 2 Operation, N One
you'll get an answer right.
Place the result back onto the
stack.
Keep doing this.
Ultimately, what you have in the
stack is the final answer.
Yeah, let's do this.
It'll be even more clear.
Evaluate this expression and
answers have been given.
So what notation is this?
Actually was, so we had this.
What notation is this?
The operator is coming after the
you know operandi AB plus.
So it is in postfix.
So as a first step, let me just
substitute them right for one
for a M substituting one for BM,
putting 2 for CM, putting 3.
So I've substituted that and
I've got this and I have added
this extra bracket.
Also, I have only added it when
I come to that bracket.
I know that the algorithm is
over.
I will stop it there, right?
Just like a marker.
One.
So let's get started.
I prefer to do this using a
table.
You can also follow that if you
like, yeah.
Will this work only for
arithmetic logical as well?
If yes, if what it will work
only for arithmetic.
Yeah, this is for arithmetic
evaluation, not logical
evaluation.
Yeah.
Cool.
Let's get started.
Sky left to go from left to
right, right.
First I encounter a symbol one,
so is 1 an operator or operand?
Yeah, real quick.
Operand correct while push it
onto the stack so the stack in
this case my example is growing
in this direction.
In this direction guys, instead
of something like this, it is
growing in this direction all
are the same.
Yeah, so now it is stack is 1
again I encounter 2.
Two is also an operand, so I
push it onto the stack.
Something like that.
So who's the topmost element
here?
Yeah.
Who's the topmost element here?
Yeah, very good.
22 is the topmost element and
then I am going to a place less
is an operator, so if it is an
operator, what did the algorithm
say?
It told Pop the top two elements
the top most element is north
one, the second of most element
is N2.
Perform in two Operation N One
that is N2 is 1 and then N N1 is
2.
I do this operation plus that is
1 + 2 is 3.
I get an answer three.
Put that answer again back to
the stack.
Right, so now only three is
there in the stack, right?
Again, encounter a new three.
This three right three is an
operand, so push it onto the
stack.
Yeah, very good.
Top element is 3 now also
topped.
This is the top most this, the
second top most encounter a
minus, so pop the topmost second
topmost, perform N 2 up north
one.
I got zero again push it onto
the stack.
That encounter 2.
Push it onto the stack.
I encounter one feet on to the
stack, so now my stack looks
like this zero to one.
You guys will tell me what is
the topmost here?
Who is the topmost?
Who is this second topmost?
Yeah, one is the top post,
second is the two is the second
top most right.
So now I'm getting a plus
symbol.
Here again I'm.
I'm scanning this expression
guys.
Yeah, one by one.
I'm getting this to one plus
this plus is what I'm currently
at, so an encounter that plus I
bought this one that is N1I
popped this two only two
elements.
You should pop the top most
becomes N1, the next one becomes
N 2.
You are doing N2 0PN one, so you
are doing 2 + 1 not 1 + 2.
Yeah, 2 + 1 is 3.
You got the answer 3.
So these two only got removed.
Zero was already there, right?
So the zero is already there.
This new answer three also you
are pushing so it became 0 comma
three.
This is my stack status now
again have a 3.
Here is an operand, so I push it
onto the stack.
So 033 I have a power symbol, so
I pop this three.
This three I do three power
Operation, 3 right 3 into 3 into
3 right or three power right
that is 27.
So I again push it onto the
stack.
So I have zero comma 27 there, I
have a minus symbol.
So this 27 top most becomes N1.
The zero becomes N2 always.
We were doing N 2 operation and
one so 0 -, 27 is minus 27.
I push it onto the stack and now
I have encountered my last
bracket which I had only put, so
I will stop my algorithm.
Whatever is there in the stack,
I'll pop it.
That will become my final answer
and my staff will become empty.
I'll tell you a small trick.
If you complete this properly,
exactly how we did now and in
the stack.
If you have multiple items, if
you have multi here we had only
minus 27 which is the answer.
But if you have multiple
answers, then there are two
cases.
Either you have made a mistake
as simple as that you have made
a mistake somewhere and that is
why you have multiple answers in
the stack at the end or or the
other case would be this given
expression itself is a wrong
expression, then also that can
happen.
Yeah.
Is this clear?
Guys, all of you in this
example, if you saw properly you
had at the end of the you know
some you had only one answer in
the stack.
That is the correct answer.
If there are multiple, you have
made a mistake or this given
question itself is a wrong
expression, right?
Yeah.
No, you will be given. Yeah.
So you can verify your steps and
if you have done everything
correctly then you can claim
that you know what the question
itself is wrong or there are
other sophisticated ones.
That is, you can reconvert this
into infix notation, and that
will.
That will have something like a
+, -, B, something like that,
which is wrong, right?
You can verify and prove like
that.
I'll not put you into all the
trouble.
Yeah, I'll give you a valid
expression, if at all this comes
in the exam.
Yeah, but if you make some
mistakes, you will have multiple
things here in this stack
finally.
Yeah, you just example clear
guys for all of you.
There are no element, is there?
You are taking N2A0?
No, not at all.
There is an element 0 here,
right?
Zero is here, right?
There was the answer I got here
and that was pushed.
I'm not clear on the three power
three.
What is 3 power?
Three, that nothing but three
power.
Three guys?
Yeah, that's like 3 square into
three, right, 99 into 327.
That one, what would happen if
the last no operator present
like this?
Uh, case minus will not be
present.
No, this is not a minus.
Yeah, this is nil here.
Yeah, if this minus is not
present, then there is something
wrong with the expression
itself, correct?
Yeah.
Can you explain the last of
which step?
So I'm not sure why you are
getting unnecessarily confused.
So till here is everyone clear?
Yes.
No, all of you.
Yes, we are only put that, yeah,
so that is why you have to be
really careful about now.
Yeah, every slide is important.
They're very step first step
says add this to the end of the
expression.
Yeah.
So if you see here here itself
that bracket was not there, I
only added it when I approached
that bracket.
I know my problem is over.
Yeah, that's like an end of line
marker.
I could have put anything for
that.
Yeah, it doesn't matter that you
have to put that close bracket.
Only.
I can put something else like
dollar or something also which
is not a valid operator in Max
right?
You can put anything build this
line.
Everyone is clear.
Yeah, I have three things here.
I encountered an operator, so
this three became popped out.
These three also popped out, but
zero is still here 0 still there
in the stack.
Yeah, I did this.
I got answer as 3 into 3 into 3
which is 27 and that also I
pushed it here and then I again
got a subtraction.
So I popped this 27 here.
I popped this zero here.
I did 0 -, 27 which is minus 27,
right?
So both of these were popped, so
stack was empty.
This minus 27 alone got pushed
and now I encountered this final
bracket.
So my problem is over and this
27 is my answer.
Wait, please perform Beaver.
Yeah, what about this
expression?
This place is coming here.
This is coming way later,
correct.
So I am going from left to right
one after the other.
So first, if this place comes,
I'm already doing it, then I'm
encountering this minus I'm
doing that this place I'll do
next.
Then I'll do this power, and
then I'll do the subtraction,
right?
Yeah, RUMIK, is that clear?
What is 0 -?
21 If we go left to right, yeah.
So that is what again and again
I was selling expression, we are
scanning from left to right,
whereas operation here we are
doing end to open one right.
So this is the topmost which
goes to N1.
This zero goes to end two, so we
are doing N2O, PN, 10 minus N 1
here.
Also, we are doing 2 + 1 not.
We are doing 1 + 2.
Yeah, if you do it the other
way, you will get a wrong
answer.
Yeah.
And that is also because there's
a beautiful logic behind why we
are doing N 2 N one.
That is to you know, follow your
math rules like this bot mass
and others.
Yeah, if you don't use that,
then you'll do N1.
Open two, you'll get wrong
answers.
Cool 2.
Practice it.
Yeah.
When I talk about this, it'll
all seem fine, but no practice
it.
I have a couple of questions for
you here.
Yeah, this is all a boost fix
expression.
Substitute the values, add A
bracket here and try to solve
these problems.
But there are two problems that
I've given you exactly same way.
Try to do it.
Please don't do anything else.
Yeah, line by line if you do it
also it's fine or do it like a
table like this and exactly
trace it like how we have done
it will not make any mistakes.
Yeah, you cannot do it for
infix.
This algorithm is only for
postfix, so if you have an infix
notation, there are two steps.
If you have in fix first you
have to convert that expression
itself into postfix and then
that postfix expression you need
to evaluate and for converting
in fix to this also my stack
will help me and to evaluate
also my stack will help me right
and this conversion algorithm I
have given it in this deck in
Appendix Appendix this is there
and this post fix evaluation we
have learned it now is this
clear?
Cool.
If that is clear, you can
actually take a very quick
break.
We'll come back in 5 minutes.
Yeah, while converting the infix
to postfix, the operators follow
selectivity, yes.
Yeah, it will follow.
We take a very short 5 minute
break and then we'll be back and
for this the also trick is that
once you complete this problems
you can actually go to this URL
and if you paste this problem
you'll actually get the complete
table like this.
You can verify this solution.
Yeah, you need not wait for me
or you need not wait for your
friends.
You can actually verify your own
answer is correct or not.
Yeah, please don't directly go
put there.
Yeah, do it on your own.
See how stack is being used.
See the correct answer and then
try to put it in this URL.
It's called postfix evaluator
and then you can see your
answer.
For one question on stack
operations to delete bottom
element, we might end up
deleting all the elements before
bottom 1, correct?
So we might lose all the
elements before bottom one.
Yes, that's right, Ajay.
That is the whole point of spec.
Yeah.
For example, there is a stack of
rotis.
If you want to remove the bottom
one, you cannot do that.
You'll have to eat all the
routes and then take the last
one, meaning you would have to
delete all the top ones.
That is by design here.
Here here.
Yeah, that is the whole point.
Krishna, you have to put it in
the canvas discussion and chit
chat with others and you know
see if you are in the right
direction.
I have multiple people got the
same answer.
If I'm giving the answer then
there is no point, right?
Yeah, you have to make your
connections.
So by now we all know at least
fifty other people in your
class.
Yeah, no.
That's saddening to here, at
least these activities will make
you do it.
Yeah, in the canvas, you know,
just stack people ask them for,
you know, if your answers are
right, you will have your
assignments in another 10 days.
Yeah, you'll be working in
groups.
Yeah.
So don't even know who's the
group member.
Then how would you do justice,
right?
And then will Peter's even more
very important?
Yeah, because in your in on
campus, students stay together.
They're in the same hostel and
so on.
And you know that happens.
But in WILP, if you are not
making any connections then it
really becomes difficult after a
point.
It is star 12 four in question.
Uh, where, exactly?
Yeah, correct.
Yeah, so this is multiply.
This 12 is a single number and
this four is a single number.
Here 24 is also single number.
There's here.
There's a space right?
575 rolls out, right?
OK, already got assignments for
two subjects. Nice.
But as Inman groups are just
small right SURYA, you might
know just another four or five.
Maybe, but what about 5000
people?
That should also be one of your
hidden agendas.
Sort of this program.
Right to make a lot more
connections learn from each
other.
Make job referrals or maybe one
of you start a company.
You can, you know, high to your
friends, or that can happen,
right?
One general question, why are we
not allowed to watch other
section recordings?
Section 2.
People want to listen to your
sessions.
OK, let's let's forget about the
online mode for now.
And if you are in a real
classroom, will you be able to
attend in two classes?
Yeah, venkat.
Mehta and S1 also is still not
so matured where you are sitting
in two classrooms, right?
So that's the same principle.
Yeah.
We follow the same guideline,
even if it is online or offline.
A student belongs to one
section.
Yeah, which is what, you know,
it is you.
You belong to that section.
You follow that and these are
unnecessary confusions on, you
know.
But topic wise I will guarantee
that it is exactly the same
topic.
It is exactly the same depth. We
will be covering.
Yeah, I know.
Raghu and Sarah, for, like
decades?
Exactly the same topic, exactly
the same thing will be covered.
There's nothing extra.
There's nothing less these
exercises.
Maybe I might be giving
something extra.
He might be giving something
else, but all this doesn't
matter.
As I told, none of these
excesses will come in your exam.
Yeah, it doesn't matter.
There is a 12, four and 24 in
the second question.
Yes, correct.
That's right, NANDINI.
So I would say is is assignment
mandatory?
What if you have missed any
assignment?
Then what will happen if we
still give another uh assignment
and eligible?
But yeah, that is still
possible.
Yeah, if you if you don't give
an assignment then you'll get 0
on that assignment.
But if you are still able to
pull it off, for example, if you
write the midterm exam, if you
write the final exam, and if you
are able to still pass the
course, then that's fine.
Yeah, but mid semester and final
are mandatory.
You cannot tell that.
I'll do the assignments, but
I'll skip them at some store
final EC2 exam and EC3 exam are
mandatory, whereas your
assignments is up to you.
I mean, if you're confident that
you will clear the course only
with midterm and final, then
it's up to you.
Cool guys, I think it's good
time for us to get started.
Let's you know chat about these
later, but yeah, you are on the
right direction.
I do remember that you know,
these are the solutions, but you
can also test it here.
As I told once I upload the
slides, you can click on this
URL, you can just copy paste
this question and you will get
the answer.
Then yeah, and space is also you
will get of course, right.
So once you get this question,
you can actually copy this line
and you will know where the
spaces are. Cool.
Right.
So let's get started with the
next data structure.
So what are the heart of?
You know stack.
What are the two operations
there?
Yeah.
Can you real quick tell me.
Yeah, push and pop.
Yeah, push and pop are the heart
of it.
That is insert and remove and it
follows the paradigm of LIFO.
This is exactly the opposite of
it.
AQ differs from a stack in that
sense that it's insertion and
removal routines follow FIFO,
meaning the first one will be
the first one to get out, and
then he has these operations
that is insertion, he's called
enquiring, and deletion or
removal is called.
Dequeuing elements may be
inserted at any time, but only
the element which has been in
the queue for the longest may be
remote and who will be there in
the longest.
The one who enter in first
right, he was in the queue for a
long time, so he'll be the one
to get out.
Elements are inserted at the
rear end and they are removed
from the front end, right?
So elements go get joined here
in the rear end.
Now there is no one thing called
top.
Yeah, there are two things right
from the rear end.
Things will go get joined,
right?
Get joined here in the queue and
from the front end people will
get removed right?
And insertion is called N
queuing and removal is called
dequeuing.
Somebody life examples.
So for example, you have a toll
gate here, right?
So this is the first one, first
car to come in and he's standing
here.
He will be the first one to get
out, so this is the front end
and this is the rear end where
newer cars are, you know, going
on and standing enter from one
leaf from the other.
Exactly from the one you enter
is called errand from the one
you leave is called as the front
end, right?
Similarly, for example, if there
is a banker here right, you will
go get yourself added here in
the queue, right?
Who will be the first one to get
out?
Your life cues also have same
case where someone in the middle
drops out and everyone behind
them moves up a position.
Yeah, you can do that.
Yeah, but in these type of
examples, we won't allow someone
to, you know, drop out.
And so on.
Usually, yeah, but you can do
that if someone moves you can,
you know, compact the other one.
So one will go out first, then
two will go out and so on.
So then the teller is sitting in
which end and someone gets that
Teller isn't.
Which end of the queue is he in
the front end or is he in the
rear end? Very good?
Yeah, he's in the front end.
From print you get removed and
in the rare end people are going
and standing in the queue.
Well, is the concept clear for
all of you?
3-4 first one gets out first.
Yeah.
The last one we'll get out last
simple stuff.
Yeah.
What are the different
operations that you can do in
the stack?
You can do top.
You can do push.
You can do pop all that.
Here you can do NQ, NQ, meaning
insert, right.
If you want to insert, do you
want to have an element?
Yes, right.
This is O.
Yeah, this is the element that I
want to insert.
Great insert object O at the
rare of the queue.
Again, there can be an error,
right?
An error occurs if the queue is
full.
If the queue itself is full,
then how can I still insert in
the stack world?
What is this error called?
Yeah, real quick theme edge
cases there also in stack there
it is called as Stack Overflow.
Our stack full.
Here it is called Q full, yeah.
Perfect, that is N queuing.
This is equal into your push
operation there and here DQ
again for DQ, you don't have any
element given here. Why?
Yeah, queue also you can write
it using array.
Yeah.
The underlying is, sorry.
Exactly.
Yeah, very good.
So I have not given any element
to remove because here also it
follows a paradigm right?
Only the first one, the first
element who went into the queue
will be the first one to get out
or the one given by friend.
He will be the one to get out.
Yeah, AD stands for abstract
data type.
Yeah.
So this very good question,
right?
We did not touch upon that.
So your integer, your string,
your character, your array.
So these things are your basic
data types, which any language
gives you correct you skew and
these type of things already
there through the posing 3
programming is a queue directly
available for you.
Yeah, MANISHA, don't really
right.
It is just a concept, it it's a
concept which says that you know
last one will come out first,
first one will 1st and all that
we only four right?
So these are called abstract
data types which you create
using the other built-in data
types using your array using
your linked list, you are
actually creating these type of
abstract data types and you will
only expose the operations you
will tell you can do Anqing you
can do dequeuing, you can know
the front only these methods you
will expose.
They will not know the internal
working and all that.
Yeah, but in advanced
programming languages, they have
made these available already,
like in your you know, Python
And so on.
It's already available.
Yeah. And this?
Yes, is the name of it.
8 stands for abstract data type
which is queue in this example.
And yes, is the name of that
what does DQ do?
It removes the object from the
front of the queue.
Again, there can be a problem if
the queue is empty.
I cannot remove anything.
Yeah, that's right.
What about friend?
Print is equivalent to which
method we learned in stack.
Anyone remember was there?
He will return an element.
Our top, very good.
He'll return the topmost element
there.
Here also it returns but does
not remove it, not remove it.
I'll just give you who is in the
front of the queue.
Basically, this friend gives you
the potential element will get
removed when you invoke a DQ
operation.
Correct.
Cool here.
Also, there can be an error if
the queue is empty, then there
is nothing.
Then what will it return?
As for it, so these are the
methods.
Yeah.
Is this clear case all of you?
What is the queue?
The example and the operations
that we can do.
Yeah.
It's in the hit list, correct?
What is?
Yes.
And O is just a variable name,
it can have any item, any
variable or you know, I mean
it's just a variable name.
And yes, is the name of this
whole queue.
I have named it as.
Yes, you can name it as queue or
anything.
Yeah.
Is that clear?
OK.
Well, let then let's you know
implement it just like the
stack.
It's implemented using an array,
right?
Create a queue using an array,
meaning you are going to specify
a maximum size capital north,
right.
Same thing.
The moment this line you have
it, can you think about some
disadvantages of queue the
moment this line comes you are
going to use an array to create
a queue, meaning you are going
to put a capital N directly.
You know that there is a problem
of this limited size.
It cannot dynamically grow or
shrink.
That problem is already there,
right?
The problem of array directly
comes as a problem of queues.
For now.
All right, let's proceed ahead.
The queue consists of an element
array, queue.
So previous example I had named
it yes.
Now I'm naming it as Q and two
integer variables because in
stack you had only one guy
called tea which is the top.
But here I have two directions
right.
I have to insert in One
Direction, remove in another
direction.
So I need two.
So yeah, very, very important
definitions, guys.
Yeah, there is a very subtle
difference here.
It's an open book exam.
You can of course look at it in
the final, but for Midsem and
others, you'll have to be
focused.
Yeah, look at the definition.
Yeah, yesterday the index of the
front element, which is the
candidate to be removed by a
dequeue operation, it is
pointing to that front element
itself, which is going to be
deleted if you call the deque
operation are R is the index of
the next available array cell,
meaning he's always pointing to
an empty cell cell, which can be
used by the enqueue operation.
Did you get the difference,
guys?
Yeah, Rajesh, Krishna, all of
you Simran.
If will always point you to an
element which is already
occupied.
Yeah.
No, not just two indices.
Yuvraj, there is a very
important difference here.
Look at this index of different
element, meaning he will always
point to an element where you
know there is some data which
can be removed.
Whereas R always points to the
index of the next available
array cell, meaning he's going
to point to an empty location
which will be used when you
perform a enqueue operation.
Getting it right, we will see
them.
Example.
It'll be more here in this
example.
Let's say F is pointing here and
R is pointing here.
Here itself, the difference is
very clear, right?
Our is pointing to an empty
place, meaning when I do an
enqueue operation, I want to
insert hundred.
I will put my unread here.
I will take my R to the next
cell, meaning R will always
point to an empty cell which can
be used by the insert operation.
And queue right.
Whereas if this pointing to an
existing element that is,
whenever I want to do a dequeue
when I delete something, this
will get deleted and if will go
point to the next element.
Yeah.
Is this clear for all of you?
No, there is no such relations
or equal to F + 1 and so on.
Initially both of them start
here and once you start
inserting, our alone keeps
growing.
F will still point there.
Let me take an example like
this.
You know, for the time being,
just, you know, ignore all this.
Let's take this example.
Initially both of them are F and
are both of them are pointing to
0 here yeah.
Yeah, because we had already
deleted some example.
We had deleted all these cells,
so if I had come here, what?
But now let's see this example.
I'm inserting an element 100.
You will tell me where we'll FB
where will R be.
Just go by their definition.
If will point to the element
which is the first one to get
deleted, whereas R will point to
the empty cell.
Very good.
Yeah, will remain at 0, whereas
R will go to the next position.
Well, I'm inserting another
element 200.
Where will you FB where will R
be in indexes?
You will tell me.
Yeah.
Yeah, we'll still remain at zero
because I have not deleted
anything, whereas R will go to
two.
Yeah.
Or we'll go to two while insert
300 here date.
I want to insert another element
so R will not point to this.
Are will go to three.
I'll insert that element right
and R would have gone to four
already.
At this stage I am now so far so
good.
All of you?
No, initially all are at zero,
yeah.
So far so good, all of you.
If stays at zero or keeps
increasing and wins it.
OK, cool.
Now let's delete.
Now I want to delete an element.
You will tell me which element
will get deleted which actual
element.
Yeah, very good.
100 will get deleted.
Yeah, that's absolutely right.
I'll go ahead.
I'll delete this under it right
and now where Will F point?
Every little it where is the F
going to fine now?
Yeah.
Yeah, becomes one very good.
F is pointing to 200 now.
I want to again delete 200 also
where will if go I want to
delete my 200 also now.
Right, this is my current state
here.
You want it got deleted?
F is always going to point to me
print element so 200 got deleted
and where will F point now?
Yeah.
If will point it the second
pollution, which is 300, this
concept is it clear guys always
if is going to point me to the
potential first element who can
be deleted right.
OK, now let's see something
interesting with this.
I want to insert another
element. Yeah.
How do we deal insert, insert, I
increment RI, insert, increment,
RI, insert, I increment R.
So what happened to R now?
Yeah.
What happened to R?
It's already filled.
What error will I throw?
I put an error that you know
what I've already inserted till
700 and now I don't have anymore
too, you know, accommodate you?
No.
Is that you're really full.
Think about it.
Summit was right.
All of you think about it, and
let's assume I'm also deleting
300.
I'm also deleting 400.
I'm also deleting 500.
I'm also deleting 600, so at
this stage where is my F
pointing to our was already out
of bound.
You throw an error and where is
pointing now 700.
Meaning, actually speaking, all
these cells are empty.
But still you complained that
queue is full, right?
But this is a problem with
normal cube that is, even though
there are empty space in the
beginning, if you hit the
threshold you will complain that
the queue is full when actually
it is not full.
There might be empty slots in
the beginning, right?
That is, what is it?
Vantage repeatedly in queuing
and dequeuing the single element
10 times will make this happen
where Fr all of them start
pointing to that last element.
No more elements can be added to
the queue, though there is space
in the queue, right though there
is space, all these cells are
empty, but still since R reached
here, you are complaining that
he is full, right?
So what is the solution for
this? Yeah.
What is the solution?
Yeah.
What can we think about?
Will values not be transferred
from zero?
Will be transferred?
Yeah, they'll all be in the same
place.
Only you should not transfer
explicitly doing all that but
circular.
Can we imagine right if I hit
this last threshold, I will go
back and check the first
position.
If these are all also, you know
filled, then I will claim that
it is full.
Otherwise I can use this place
right?
Yeah, this implementation isn't
fully utilizing.
The space is allocated.
However, if we implement
reordering arrange front, yes.
But if you implement the other
way, that is called a circular
queue.
Yeah.
So this is a normal queue.
The normal queue has this
problem, yeah.
If you use normal queue, this
problem will happen.
So we will go for something
called as a circular queue.
Circular queues are one where
from the last you are again
joining it back to the first
one.
After this you are again join it
to the first one.
It looks something like this
lake parent is here.
Then you have kept on inserting
items and then you know you'll
after the seven.
You'll again go back to the
zeroth position, and if this was
empty then you could have
utilized it right?
Is it clear, guys?
It's also called as a wrapped
around configuration where the
last one and the first one are
wrapped around something to form
like a circle.
But now there is another point.
So for front and rear, we were
just doing rare plus plus or
friend plus plus.
But here when I have a circle,
will that still work?
Yeah, after seven.
So for example, here rare is
pointing to five.
I add another element.
I add a another element from 7.
If I do another increment, it
will go to eat, it'll go to 9
and so on.
But I wanted to come back to the
front location.
So who will help us?
Very good.
Yeah, the mod operation will
help us if you do modulus
operation, then after the seven
if you do 7 + 1 module is 8,
it'll become eight.
Model is 8 which is 0, so you'll
again come back to the first
location and you will keep
rotating inside this particular
circle.
Yeah.
Is this clear guys for all of
you?
That's why we are doing or equal
to R + 1 mod N if equal to F + 1
mod N.
All of you the exact same thing,
unless all of them got get
occupied, there will not be any,
you know, problems.
But now when Ari is full, for
example, here I put.
And now, rare also has come
here.
So no friend and rare both of
them are in the zeroth place.
Is the Q full or Q empty now?
Yeah, Vijay got it's a very
simple concept.
Since we have a queue, can I
have indexes going above 7 here?
When it is a normal thing like
this, I can keep incrementing
and here I can claim that it is
out of bound, but when it is
circular I wanted to go back to
zero.
And how will I make it to go
back?
That is where I use the mod
operation.
If I do a modulus operation, I
will again be back to this zero
position, right?
That is why we are using the
modulus and now I had another
question here.
When will I know the queue is
full or empty?
Those initially, we told the
definition that a front and rare
are at zero.
It means that is empty.
So here, front and rear, both of
them are in 0, but now is the
queue full or empty?
Right when arrays full F is
equal to R, same as empty
condition then how do we know if
it is a queue full or QMT?
There are many ways to handle
this actually.
Yeah, you can actually do.
If rare is, you know, front or
equal to 0 and condition and if
this element is not empty then
you can know that it is actually
not having values something like
that.
There are many ways to approach
it.
A simple approach is to handle.
This is to insist the queue can
never hold more than North minus
one object.
Unfortunately, this is the
textbook way.
Yeah, very pathetic way.
Yeah.
So they are not wanting you to
put more than you know the six
elements.
The cell will always be empty.
Yeah.
So and they have of course
explained it for you to try it
later on.
You know how to handle this
condition and all that, but is
this clear guys?
Yes.
No.
If you want to know if it is
full or empty, it is not very
trivial.
You might have to do some extra
check, meaning you'll have to
check that if rent and Ray are
both 0, or if they're equal, and
if that cells have some value.
If it is not equal to well, then
you can know that that is not
empty, and if it is null it
means that it is empty.
Yeah.
Similar examples, yeah.
How will you know the size of
something?
You should do the capital N
minus front plus, Sir, right?
Because you could have also
deleted some elements, right?
So you should do A minus front
plus R again.
Of course, model is so in Q it
is mandatory to move null once
we read the data.
Yes, that's a better practice,
correct?
Otherwise you will get misled
right?
Some other old number will be
there, right?
So you should not do that.
If are equally equal to F and
exactly that's right.
What if it is empty?
Yeah, this is the textbook way
of doing.
Again, this is a little, you
know, controversial, right?
If you use the textbook way,
this will work.
Otherwise this equal to R can
give problem and what your
friend just suggested is the
right answer.
Yeah, CHARAN told you, right.
If equal to R and if that
element is not null.
Yeah.
Is it clear, guys, all of you?
Of course I will give you the
notebook which is having the
right implementation, not the
textbook way, yeah.
Print element if it is empty
then throw an error.
Otherwise, give the front
element queue of F like you you
don't give any input because you
know that the front element is
the one who will be deleted.
You check for error if there is
elements you can delete him.
Similar to stack, you take that
element and keep it in a
variable so that you can tell
that was the guy who got
deleted.
Otherwise make it null and do
front equal to friend plus plus,
but you cannot just do front
plus.
Plus, because there is a
circular queue, so you need to
use mod N similarly for MQ you
need an insert operation.
You need what is to be inserted,
but you have to check for the
edge condition.
There might be cases that the
queue is full, so you check for
that.
You put error, otherwise you can
insert you do in that R position
you insert your item and you do
R Plus plus, but you cannot just
do plain R Plus.
Plus, because it is circular
queue, so you are doing R Plus
plus modules here.
Yeah.
No, you will just use circular
form Vijay.
Yeah.
We will not go for that because
it has a major problem, right,
even if it has empty spaces, we
have still complain that I
cannot insert.
So whenever we are talking about
queue, we will actually use the
circular form only.
Yeah, unless it's explicitly
told to you, it is understood
that we will use the circular
form only. Yeah.
Sai is equal to n -, R which
line this this one you mean?
OK, it's all very trivial guys.
Yeah, don't get confused.
There is a queue.
It's app around.
I put some elements, I've
deleted them now.
Now my first pointing here and
may R is pointing here.
So how do we get the total size
right from the total capital?
North, I must subtract my
because I deleted these parts
and then I should add my this R
that will give my. Yeah.
Is it clear?
Yes.
No, maybe, but yeah, I will
recommend you to take an actual,
you know queue, put the indices
in trace these programs.
Yeah.
So something like you know?
Take a cue like this and
actually put some numbers.
Give them index values.
Right.
And then try to go ahead and
trace each of the lines.
Then you will be able to get a
better picture.
Yeah, there's the end.
Is your capacity F is your
friend, or is your rare?
Since there are options that you
have inserted something and then
deleted them, so you need to
account for that F also.
That is why there is a minus CF
plus R.
Yeah, his empty,
straightforward.
We already discussed both of
them are same and if that
element also if that queue of F
is equally equal to null then it
means it is empty.
But R will point to MD place.
Uh, how can we directly?
R will not point to an empty
place, right?
R location is empty, but R will
still point.
For example, in this case R will
.23 that is not empty, correct?
Are you getting it?
Q of R is empty that is not
having anything here, but R is
still pointing to three, right?
So I should be calculating
something like that.
Yes. No.
Yeah, for the circular example
will give size as seven, but we
should have, uh, six.
No, not really.
So we are talking about size
guys, not capital N so for this
example, what is capital N?
Yeah, calculation is based on
indices, of course.
Yeah, the whole example revolves
around indices, not the actual,
you know, value here.
Capital N is 6, where is F even
now?
If I have not deleted anything,
so if I still pointing me to 0,
great.
If we're still pointing to zero
and where is our pointing to, R
is pointing to three here right
to the Mt slot.
So what did the formula say?
Formula told 6 -, 3 +, 0, that
is 6 -, 3 which is 3.
That is my size, so here there
is 123 elements.
So my formalize correct?
Right.
What if I had deleted this
hundred?
If this F was pointing to one
right, then this F will be one,
so this will become 3 + 1 four 6
-.
Four will become two.
That is my size which is this
300 and 200.
You get the point, right?
All of you, we have to account
for that F correct.
Otherwise, you know, if you keep
deleting in the beginning only
our if you have in the formula
you will get misled.
That is why we had all that so
size is including the empty
place.
No.
Yeah, you have to take the R
value, but once you apply the
formula you will get the correct
answer.
Hello again.
Urge Krishna, please take the
you know examples and trace it.
Yeah, and only if you trace it.
You will get it as a better
picture, but you were right, we
should have taken the actual,
you know, let's take this
example.
You will tell me where is F?
You'll tell me where is R?
Yeah, real quick.
Yeah, we're losing time on, you
know, very, very trivial things
real quick.
Where is F0, where is R?
It is not four.
Yeah.
Again, someone told four no.
Yeah, it is pointing to the
empty location which is 5,
right?
What is capital N here?
Capital N is how many slots are
there 12345678 right.
Capital N is 8 correct, though
formula ways 8 -, 0 + 5, that is
8 -, 5, right.
Yes, no.
So what is the answer we got?
3.
Why 7 frame?
Right.
Can you please explain with an
example how mod calculation is
done?
Come on, guys.
Yeah, we are doing master
scores, right.
This is 8 if it is having three
to divide it by three and then
three tools are is 6 and
remainder.
This is your model is sensor.
Yeah, the remainder answer is
your total answer, correct, yes,
no.
Yeah.
So n -, F + R, right.
So what did we do?
This is my capital N minus my F
+ R right?
So my R was here.
It is pointing me to five and my
capital N is nothing but eight
and my friend is still pointing
me to 0 right.
So this is what we got, right?
So this was my three right but
here how many elements are
there?
What is the size here?
Is it 3 or is it 5?
Yeah.
You mean this capital N -?
F + R someone told that yeah,
even if you do that, F + R is
nothing but five 8 -.
Five is 3 only, but here you
have wrong rate.
So is this formula correct or
wrong? Yeah.
Yes.
No, maybe.
Yeah, n -, F, less R and then
you also have something here.
What is this part?
Right, it is modulus N again
right?
Yeah, so please try to do this
and also I will upload a
notebook as I told your textbook
way of queue is a little wrong.
Yeah, it is a little wrong
because they go with some
assumptions that you know you
should not allow more than you
know and minus one object and so
on, which is not the right way.
So then you will get the right
thing, right?
So do practice this.
I will also upload the notebook
which will have the right one.
Yeah, don't get confused with
this.
Yeah.
Is it clear, guys, all of you?
Yes.
No.
Maybe all of you got this.
13 mod 8 right, so you should
not forget this mod part also
right?
Otherwise you will, you know, go
for a bigger confusion.
But here it was all correct.
Right 8 + 5 gave you 1313 mod 8
gave you 5 which was the size of
it, but it right all of you.
Yes.
No.
Maybe as long as you keep
deleting your F, this F value
would have increased
accordingly.
It will give you the right
answers right?
Yes.
No, maybe.
It is n -, F + R only correct.
Cool.
So what are the different
applications of this?
Right, so your computers will
not work without queues.
Yeah, as simple as that.
So internally there is some
advanced concept of CPU
scheduling, right?
So even if I have multiple
applications, they'll switch
quickly between them and so on.
So it uses CPU scheduling,
users, queues, plenty of queues
called short term, you know
ready queue, waiting queue and
all that and your disk
scheduling also uses queues.
There is something called as
priority queues.
We will look at it later in this
course and that will also be
heavily used in, you know, heaps
and other advanced algorithms.
And at that time, we will have a
look at this.
Yeah.
Is it clear these all of you?
Yes.
No, maybe.
Aris places and minus.
We already saw it is fast, but
it is impossible to resize.
But many applications will
require resizing, right?
And the required size might not
be available.
So that was the problem of array
and because we used array to
implement stack and queue, they
also got the same problems
right?
So in order to avoid all that,
we will learn something about
list or linked list, right?
A list is a sequence of items
where positional order matter
and it is very general in
computing a list of students, a
list of event and things like
that, right?
So what are the operations that
we can do on a stack real quick?
Yeah, real quick.
What are the operations that we
can do on a stack push pop top?
What about Q?
What can we do on a queue?
Yeah, in queue, what else we can
do?
NQDQ and friend, right?
But in a list you can do a lot
more things.
You can know what who is first,
who is last.
You can give someone and ask is
this the first position or you
can give some position and ask
is this the last or you can ask
who is before this who is.
After this you can ask the size
and so on right a lot more you
can do.
You can insert after something
you can remove before someone
and all this.
You can do a lot more operations
on a list.
Yeah.
So what is a list now?
So a singly linked list is a
concrete data structure
consisting of a sequence of
nodes and now what is a node?
Right?
So this square one is a node.
There's a note it is going to
have two compartments.
One will have the actual element
and the next one is a pointer to
the next element.
Alright, so now this is a linked
list.
This is a single linked list.
But I have E and then the
pointer to the next one and so
one.
Right.
Let me just go ahead and take.
Let's suppose this isn't address
4000.
This is an address 8000.
This is in 8400 and this is in
say 9100.
No, this 8000 will be here and
this will have 8400.
Maybe this is not very visible.
8000 will be here.
8400 is here.
9100 is here and here you have
empty.
Yeah.
Is it clear for all of you guys?
So a node contains 2
compartments.
The first one is the element
part, the second one is the
pointer to the next node, so
right it will have that address
of the next node, right?
So now is it linear in the
memory?
Is this data structure linear in
the memory?
Makes an explosion.
It is not.
It can be anywhere in the
memory, but it is still a linear
data structure.
You can always go from A to BB
to CC2D only, right?
But there is some disadvantage
here, correct?
Let's say suppose you are in D
if you are in D, will you be
able to go back to a?
If you are in deposition
already, you are standing here.
Will you be able to go back to a
or will you be able to go back
to B?
No, because your loss, that
pointer, all that you can do is
you'll have to again come back
from the beginning, right?
If you want to add a new one,
how will you do so?
We say that links can
dynamically grow or shrink.
How's that?
Because I can create a new node
somewhere in memory, I will name
it E I'll give the element
inside.
Let's say suppose this got
stored in memory in say address
9500.
All that I should do is I'll
have to change this to 9500.
The moment I do that, this will
start pointing here and I will
make this to be empty.
That's why I can dynamically
grow this list or when I don't
want someone I will just delete
him and I'll make its previous
pointer to be null.
That's it, right?
But as I told there is this
problem of I cannot go in the
reverse direction, right?
And that is why we have a doubly
linked list.
Now this doubly linked list node
has three compartments, one is
the actual element you have the
pointer to the next node and the
pointer to the previous node.
A doubly linked list is often
more convenient.
They have the element linked to
the previous and next node.
It also has special trailer and
header nodes which has the
address of the first node.
This is the header.
The trailer will have the last
nodes position so in either
direction you will be able to
traverse.
Yeah.
Is this clear?
Guys, all of you?
Yes.
No, maybe.
Cool.
But now I want to go to the
frog.
This position I want to go
really be able to directly go to
the frog just like an array.
I don't even know where this
frog is.
Right.
I should start from the header.
I should take the address.
I should go here.
I should take the next address.
I should go here and check if
this is frog.
No, I'll take the next address.
I'll go here.
I'll check if it is frog. Yes.
So what is the complexity?
Yeah, either from header or
trailer.
So what is the complexity?
Yeah, very good.
It is big.
Oh yen.
So I should traverse the list.
I cannot directly go take
something that I like, right?
I'll have to traverse it, which
is the disadvantage of linked
list, but there is one positive
that it can grow dynamically or
shrink.
Right, so insertion algorithm
right?
So as I told you can do a lot of
things with link list, but we
will just look at 1 insertion
and one deletion.
Yeah, the others you can
actually, you know, take a try
of these first, last and you
know is first you can actually
look at all this.
We'll just look at 2 examples.
Visualize the operation insert
after PX, meaning I want this
element X to be inserted after
the PTH position.
So firstly you have to traverse
still there, right?
I go here.
I found out this is the peak
position right?
And here between this B&CI
want to insert here.
Right.
Is the problem clear?
Base all of you?
Yes.
No, maybe I want to insert an
element after the peak position.
The peak position will be second
position, the third position,
whatever.
In this case, I have told after
the second position, so this is
the first position, the second
position.
After this I want to insert here
so there are five things that I
have to do.
I will tell each step very
clearly.
Just try to follow me.
Firstly I will create this box
correct?
I'll have to create this
compartment or node somewhere in
memory that is 1 right?
Second thing, I'll create it and
I'll have the value as X
correct?
That is what I want to insert,
that is one first step.
There is a second step involved.
That is, I'll have to update
this.
The new nodes previous and the
new nodes next.
Also I should update.
So now this node has joined to
the linked list.
So when I created him, he was an
orphan.
He was somewhere in the memory,
but the moment I have updated
this previous and next of this
node, yes come into this linked
list.
But even now, the beast next
part is not updated and C's
previous part is not updated.
So that also I should do four
and five.
So 5 operations.
If I do, I'll be able to get it
done.
Yeah.
Is this clear for all of you, a
node has three memory spaces.
Yes, that's right.
Yeah, it has three compartment
we saw here, right?
It has three compartments.
Yeah, I'll come again.
What are the very first step I
should create a node?
Do you agree to that?
All of you, that is my first
step.
This I can create an anywhere in
the memory correct?
Let's us suppose I have created
this in memory location 3000.
I've only created it.
I have put its value as X.
He's orphan now.
He's not even there in the
linked list, so I should be
updating his previous.
I should be updating this next
third operation.
I should update this, B is next.
He should now be pointing to
this node.
Britain sort of see he should
know, point to this X.
That is my 4th operation and
this sees previous he should now
not go to B.
He should go to X, so that is
May 5th Operation I operations.
You should be able to.
If we do that, then we have
successfully inserted correctly.
It's not all of you.
Visually it is clear.
Yeah, programmatically.
We we'll come there, but
visually is it clear create a
node that is step one in that
newly created node we should
update its previous and next.
So three things we have done and
then in the actual link list,
we'll have to update the
corresponding next and previous
positions.
Then the node would have got
joined like this.
Now B's next becomes **, next
becomes CC's.
Previous becomes X&X is
previous becomes B, so it's a
proper link list Now yeah.
And then he very good.
Yeah, that's exactly what we
have done here.
Create a node, set the element
as ex.
So we have a variable E this
variable E will have that value
X.
So these two I can call a test
step one.
Right.
That is step one.
B Dot set previous P This is the
second step, meaning I have set
its previous element.
V Dot set next, meaning I'm
setting is set next, but there's
a very clever way to do it.
How I have set this is if I do
we dot set next where will I go?
Can someone tell me where I will
go?
And in this particular node, if
I do.
Yeah, I want to set this next to
value, right?
I am currently residing here in
B, correct?
If I do P dot get next, what
will it give me?
This guy, right?
This guy is nothing but my C so
that is what I wanted here, so I
will copy it here for this line
is a very powerful line.
I'm telling V dot set next,
which is this compartment.
I'm copying the P dot get next
done so three steps.
Meaning I have created a node.
I have the element.
I have its previous and next but
till now also it has not.
Actually, you know fully
completed this part and this
part is not changed.
So that also we have done it in
a very, you know elegant way P
dot get next the moment I do
this, where will I go?
Michelle, can someone guess if
they do P dot getnext I would
have reached this sea in that
I'm doing C dot previous this
compartment I'm sending it to V
so that I established this link
and then I do P dot set next
meaning this value I erase it, I
set it to so I make use of this
value.
I set this C's previous first
and then I do this part.
If you interchange these two
lines it will not work right.
And finally you return the V
telling I've completed it.
So is this clear guys?
For all of you?
These two is first step.
This is second step, third step,
4th step.
Step. You're done.
Yeah, this is exactly what you
know.
And then you had put up in
words.
What will be the result of the
new node E dot getnext?
Will it give the random memory
location?
No, not really.
So this V dot get next we have
already set it right?
It'll take me to C.
Initially, before you have said
that it will give you some junk
value.
Yeah.
Is it clear, guys, all of you
try to trace them?
Yeah.
So the best way to learn this is
take some notes and as I told
have some values have 8005
thousand and all that and then
try to trace each of them right.
See see which values are going
here?
What is a pointing to?
What is this pointing to?
What is this?
What is this so trace like that?
And that is the best way to
learn. Yeah.
Will you do that?
Deletion is very simple.
Yeah, I want to remove this node
P But yeah, I want to go till
there after I go.
What is the only change I have
to do?
I love to make this point to
this and make this point to this
correct.
Are you able to visualize guys
all of you?
Currently this is the state.
I know this node I want to
delete.
That simply means I want to
point this to here.
I want to point this previous to
here and knock this full guy
off.
How?
How to find which is the P
element by value or by checking
next address no P here means the
position meaning that third node
or fifth node.
So you have to traverse that
many nodes Aishwarya, right?
So here the example says delete
the 4th row.
That's why should start from the
beginning and it has told delete
the 4th node from the beginning.
So I go here.
This is the first note I'm
keeping account as one.
I'm going here count as two.
I'm going here.
Count is 3.
I'm going here.
Count is 4, so this is the node
I want to delete.
So that is the PP tells me the
count of or the position of it.
So I have to count it and then
go there and delete it.
But delete.
Are you are able to visualize 20
simple guys?
All that I'll have to do, for
example, if you want to delete
B, some people can also give
that they will tell delete the
node with value B.
So then again, you have to
traverse and see that you know
this node is having value B.
So this is what I want to
delete.
What does the delete all
deletion entitle?
I'll have to join this to here.
I love to join this compartment
to hear A and I can just knock
him off.
Yeah.
Is everyone getting the
deletion?
I don't see any sponsors, so I'm
a little concerned.
Got no need of code, but are you
able to visualize this?
Yeah, deletion part.
If you want to delete B, I'll
have to join this here.
I'll have to join this previous
2A.
This is next will become C,
right?
So just two lines of code.
So again, this is formality I'm
taking in a variable and I'm
returning it.
I'm setting the nulls right, but
these two are the actual links
where in P dot get previous
right I'm setting the next.
I'm setting the next to P dot
getnext, right?
So if I'm in P here, what I'm
doing actually P dot get
previous will take me here in
that I'm setting the next disk
compartment.
I'm setting it to P dot get next
this one.
This one is actually the next
value, right?
So this same copying here.
Similarly in P dot getnext, the
moment I go here this
compartment I'm setting it to
this one which is nothing but P
dot get previous.
Yes, it's a very simple stuff,
but you know we have returned
some elegant one liner quotes,
but if you are new to this
please try to, you know put some
values and you know try to
practice each get previous where
are you going and set next what
are you setting, what is the
value and so on right.
Then it'll be clear.
Cool.
I think that's pretty much so.
We will continue from here in
tomorrow's class and you know,
so try to practice this and
it'll be no even more clear and
some exercises I had given in
between those, you know
evaluation of postfix and so on.
So try to do that and put it in
our sections discussion and you
know, we'll take it from there.
Yeah.
Anything else guys?